[Music]
this doughnut-shaped Earth would have a
similar position relative to the sun and
the same actual tilt it would even have
a similar escape velocity 11.4 km/s for
most of the planet at the donuts Equator
the escape Velocity would go down to
just 6 1/2
km/s so if you were going to send
Rockets into space that would be the
best place to break free of the
gravitational clutches of a donut-shaped
earth speaking of gravity depending
where you were on a Taurus Earth you'd
weigh up to three times less than you
usually
do if our round earth has a surface
gravity of 1G the surface gravity of a
donut Earth along the poles would be
0.65 G and at the Equator the gravity
would go down to just
0.3g it would be like walking on the
surface of
Mars